- A circle in the xy-plane
has its center at 7, 14.
If the point 7, 34 lies on the circle,
which of the following is
an equation of the circle?
So let's just remind
ourselves the general form
of the equation of a circle.
If any of this looks unusual to you,
if you haven't seen it before,
I encourage you to watch
the equation of a circle
videos on Khan Academy.
For the general form for
the equation of a circle,
if we have a circle that's
centered at the point h, k
The x coordinate of the center is h,
the y coordinate of the center is k.
And if it has a radius of r.
So the circle is gonna
look something like that,
I'm trying to draw it
as circular as I can.
And it's not so circular,
I think you get the point.
So the radius is r, the equation,
the equation of this circle,
of all the points that are
exactly r away from the
point h, k is gonna be
x minus the x coordinate
of the center, squared,
plus, y minus the y coordinate
is equal to the radius squared.
Now in this case we know
what our h and k is.
H is 7, and k is 14.
And we just need to figure out the radius.
If we figure that out, we
will be able to figure out
the equation of the entire circle.
Now they tell us that
the center's at 7, 14.
So that point right over there is 7, 14.
And then the point 7, 34
also lies on the circle.
So it has the same x coordinate,
its y coordinate is just higher.
That right over there
might be the point 7, 34.
It would be right above it,
we've just increased our
y without changing our x.
So 7, 14 is the center.
This point right over here,
7, 34 lies on the circle.
So the circle's gonna look,
something like this.
And so the radius of this circle,
what we have to figure out
is just the distance
between these two points.
And these two points, you
don't even have to really apply
the distance formula
or anything like this.
The distance here is just our change in y,
our x doesn't change.
It's gonna be 34 minus 14.
So the radius here is equal to 20.
So now we know.
We know h is equal to 7, k is equal to 14,
and r is equal to 20.
So it's gonna be x minus
h, x minus 7 squared plus
y minus k, y minus 14 squared,
is equal to r squared, 20 squared is 400.
And so let's see, that is
this choice right over here.
X minus 7 squared plus y minus
14 squared is equal to 400.
And we're done.